If you recall when we looked at the
application, we had three buttons across
the top of the screen, and we had
the map fragment itself underneath them.
And the basic UI that Android Studio
created for us had a single text view.
So delete that and
replace it with the layout code
that's in the instructor notes.
This is made up of a LinearLayout which
is set to be in vertical orientation.
And within this LinearLayout I then
have another LinearLayout at the top
which contains the three buttons.
And as you can see my three buttons
are Button Map, Button Satellite, and
Button Hybrid.
And then underneath this LinearLayout
for the buttons is the fragment itself
containing the map fragment similar
to what we've been doing earlier on.
So I have a linear layout putting the
buttons on top and the map underneath.
And then the second linear layout
within the first has the buttons
horizontally stacked side by side,
as you can see here.
So now if I run the application
you'll see I have the basic map
with the three buttons.
They won't do anything yet, because I
haven't written the code behind them.
Try it out yourself, see what happens,
and check your error log for details.
Typically if you have problems it's
the API key hasn't been setup properly.
And after we wire up the buttons
we'll take a look at how to do that.